since i have a few extra minutes with
you i have a few
uh i call fun questions i promise
they're softballs
um how hard is it for you to not spend
all day posting pictures of your cats
and dog on instagram
i mean i i rarely succeed not doing that
i pretty much always do that so yes
impossible
i always think they're doing cute funny
[ __ ] so i feel like you know if it
cheers me up it might cheer
four or five other people up so that
they they appear
100 also your cats seem like they're
very
chill about everything one of them
really is and one of them is
you know a junior jedi in that
department
so she there is one one of the cats is
he
happens to just like all the things i
like like dressing him up and
making him dance and he he's just
completely down for whatever the vibe is
which
isn't very cat-ish that's why it's worth
sharing you know because he's an unusual
creature
listen i can watch i can look at cat
pictures all day bring it up
um so one of the one of the search terms
regarding
your name is is kate beckinsale in lord
of the rings
i and it's a very high search term and i
don't understand
do you know the reason why people are
this is such a high search term
is it because i've got you know
large-ish feed
i i i first of all i know of it
first of all i had no idea second of all
i mean i i have a regular normal i don't
have to get a special shoe but like
you know i'm like a nine and a half but
yeah i i don't know if that qualifies
you for a hobbit
sure it's interesting that you jump you
jump to the hobbit i was just curious
how people are associating your name
with lord of the rings
and it's such a high search thing that
is really strange
i didn't know that either and that my
mind was boggling a bit
when you said search term i could i mean
please don't tell me anything worse than
that
right it was just lord of the rings okay
fine yeah that's a real mystery i have
no idea
am i maybe i am i i i've only seen one
of them
it's okay when do you you uh i am
curious when did you feel like you made
it as an actor
that you could do this for a living and
like
not work another job i think that's
always under construction
for all actors everyone's kind of going
i shouldn't do this i'm never doing it
again
you know i think it's one of those
things you just always kind of anybody
artistic
should be kind of questioning themselves
all the time um
i think there comes a point when you've
been doing it for a decade or two when
you think wow i've really screwed myself
because
now i can't become a doctor so i've kind
of left it a bit late
you know but i'm english i've never
sitting there going oh i've i've got to
that point now
we don't do that i've heard that from
other uh uh people from england uh
jumping into why i get to talk to you
today
what was it about this story and script
that said i want to do this
um one the fact that it was completely
original
and i loved the fact that it was a
female-led action comedy
that wasn't based on a video game or a
comic book
or anything else and that there was an
opportunity for this completely unique
character who
you know she's english she's kind of
it's very sassy but she's got
you know a lot of self-loathing she's
got a lot going on and she's
you know there's a nice mix of kind of
vulnerable and
sort of goofy and stuff
and i i thought it was a really
interesting story i love
i love original movies and i i love
there being more of those
especially in like the action space with
the female lead i think it's
you know something i i really like that
that's if that works well it's really
exciting
oh i'm i'm completely with you and uh
anything original
uh as you can imagine i see a lot of
movies so anything that has an original
thing i'm like bring it on
yeah exactly because i think you know i
think obviously i totally understand
that
you know if you make a movie about i
can't believe it's not butter all the i
can't believe it's not butter fans will
come and
there's a sort of guaranteed audience
but i think there's something really
cool about
you know not having an expectation of a
character or you know oh i i imagined
this person so differently when i read
the book
you know whatever like this is this is
it this is what it is she's for this
movie
and that's where she exists uh i'm
obviously a huge fan of stanley tucci
uh how hard is it yeah i mean find me
that person and let's annihilate them
a hundred percent how hard is it to work
with him
on set and not spend the day talking
about devil wears prada
or yeah or saying could you please make
a panini
for me or some amazing salad or just
tell me
anything that you think is important for
life he's just
amazing he's he's amazing and he's up
for a laugh he's a giggler um but he's
just
i adored him do you think he liked you
enough
that he will ask you to guest star on
searching for italy season two
i'm worried that he might not have but
now you've i hadn't even had that
thought and i'm gonna go ahead and
stress about it
why didn't you ask me for season one
well i mean you never know with season
one you're fini
you're figuring out the show but with
season two maybe he wants to have guest
stars
i'm already offended
i love learning about like the behind
the scenes on the making of a movie so
maybe what do you think
might surprise people to learn about the
making of jolt
how much opera laverne cox sang during
it
someone else said that to me i'm yeah i
don't know i'm not lying
there are other witnesses i had no idea
yeah nor did i then she can really get
up there
before i run out of time with you uh i'm
so curious about charlie day's
directorial debut
el tonto have you seen it what can you
teach me about this
uh you know the the plot of it i mean
it's a yeah
so i don't know i don't i'm not i'm not
quite sure i i
loved my scenes they were really funny
but i haven't seen the whole movie
together i play a sort of horrific movie
star
um that charlie marries for a minute
i cannot wait uh let me ask you about
guilty party which i believe you just
recently filmed
for what can you tease about that
project
um it's a it's another kind of comedy
drama
uh vibe it's uh it's about a journalist
woman whose kind of
marriage is a bit iffy and she's kind of
disgraced herself at work and she's not
in the best
place and so she's kind of looking for
something to save her and she finds this
young woman who's been uh in prison for
a while and she decides she's going to
try and kind of
you know tell that story and make a
difference but she's you know
she's she's flawed
they all are i understand i haven't
stopped there
seriously congrats on this and thank you
so much for giving me your time
my pleasure thanks so much